you
okay
good morning
dear
prime minister allah dear colleagues
on
the 1st of july we welcomed
the czech republic at the helm of the
council of the european union and today
it is a pleasure
to have with us prime minister fiala to
present
the programme of activities of the czech
presidency prime minister dear peter
welcome
to the european parliament
prime minister you along with the prime
ministers of poland and slovenia were
the first european leaders to visit kiev
when it was besieged in a message of
solidarity we know that european unity
with
ukraine and its people will be central
to the czech presidency's
agenda and this is why with an illegal
war on our continent your presidency
comes at a turning point
in history so our next steps will be
decisive for our
um common future this is not time
to backtrack on our ambitions we need to
address
the economic and social consequences of
the pandemic this is why we must
accelerate our digital and green
transitions and here
the czech presidency can count on the
commitment of this house to make
progress on the fit455 package as well
as the european tips act and the
artificial intelligence act
dear prime minister diapeta just a few
weeks ago you welcomed us together with
all the presidents of the leaders of the
parliamentary groups in prague
and it is in this constructive spirit
that the european parliament will
continue to work
with your presidency on uh the many
important initiatives on the table on
behalf of this house i therefore wish
you every success in the coming months
so dear prime minister i will now give
you the floor
dear members of the european parliament
madam president of the commission dear
ursula
ladies and gentlemen it's a great
pleasure to be here today to present the
czech republic's plans for our
presidency of the council of the eu this
is the second presidency for my country
but the first under the lisbon treaty we
are building on the excellent french
presidency it has managed to complete a
number of proposals successfully it was
not easy to find a compromise in
such a difficult
debate like the 50
for a fit 455 package
in the
area of climate
or
on new rules for the digital economy but
the most important thing that was
achieved during the french presidency
was a united action
to response in response to russia's
aggression against ukraine
our response was quick
it was tough
and
most importantly it was united
six packages of sanctions were not
approved easily a number of member
states had to give up their positions
some of their economic interests and
some of their comfort
but because we were convinced that it
was right to stand up to russia and to
help our friend and ally
i'm in ukraine we did it
together we also granted candidate
status to ukraine and moldova
it gave them hope
and faith in the future
and in joining free democratic europe
our presidency wants to build on this
work
and now
according to the european parliament
tradition
allow me to present the main priorities
of our presidency in my mother language
in check
ladies and gentlemen the topics and
priorities that we want to focus on
have been created over
a period of many months but 24th
february 2022 turned most of our plans
upside down literally
our priorities
reflect this new situation
we are in a time
where war is being waged just outside
the eu's borders this is a classic
conventional conflict many of us thought
was a thing of the past in europe
but apart from conventional war
russia is also waging hybrid war
intentionally
sparing a refugee wave
using energy resources as a weapon
and
by target and infrastructure it is
spurring a food crisis
from our point of view it is very good
that our membership in the eu and in
nato protects us from the most tragic
consequences
that that are being faced by the
ukrainian people
when on the 15th of march together with
the polish and slovenian prime ministers
i visited president zielenski in kiev
i saw with my very own eyes the heroism
of ukrainians who were and still are
fighting for their right to exist and
for their right to belong to western
civilized countries
this reminded me that our values were
not a matter of course that they need to
be defended day to day
or not
the values
for which ukrainians are dying these
days are values that were defended by
one of the founders of the modern czech
state
the president vars love havel it was his
inspiring essay from 1996
brought us to the motto of our
presidency
which goes europe as a task
and indeed
europe has many tasks before it
and similarly
the czech presidency of the council has
many tasks before it
the main task for the next months will
be to find a united and strong agreement
on such measures
that will dampen as much as possible the
most negative consequences of the
current crises on our citizens because
inflation unavailability of energy or
the food crisis are
threats that need to be faced and these
threats are best faced together i
believe that both the council and the
european parliament can agree on this
europe as a task is a commitment for us
it is not a given
it is something that we will need to
work on constantly that we will need to
perfect
also we need to adjust those things that
have not been working as planned
europe needs to lead by example
it needs to reflect its conscience and
it needs to face its challenges
our solutions however need to be
balanced so that
too much focus on one
does not damage or neglect another for
example social peace or our economy
the czech republic will always
very delicately try to reflect all
opinions that will be voiced in our
debates
we have to prevent
a split among us we always have to try
to find the
widest most possible agreement we have
to respect the opinions and position of
others even though we may not agree with
them
havel's words on europe as a task come
of course from another time they come
from another europe than what we have
today but their basic message remains
the same and as
strong
our motto is to rethink rebuild and
repower that reflects our challenges and
the problems of the current europe and
our reactions to them
the czech presidency will want to build
a safe and prosperous eu
such an eu that will be true to its
values of freedom and democracy an eu
that will enable all of its citizens to
travel and work freely or become engaged
in the internal market an eu which
understands that we do have an up
responsibility towards the environment
that we need to hand over to the next
generation
um
as as it is and an eu that builds on
what unites us and respects what makes
us diverse that's the eu that we want
and
in terms of this target we formulated
five pillars of the czech presidency
which i would now like to introduce to
you
the first priority
is managing the refugee crisis and a
post-war reconstruction of ukraine
the russian aggression directly or
indirectly is impacting all member
states of the eu the direct consequences
include the most massive refugee wave
since the second world war the czech
republic is one of the countries with
the highest number of ukrainian refugees
per capita
there are more than 3.5 percent refugees
in our population now
we do have our bitter experience with
russian imperialism we know what
aggressive russian policy can do the
czech republic is therefore convinced
that
political and military support of
ukraine from the eu
is in the utmost interest of the entire
eu
with direct impact on next future of our
continent
the czech presidency will therefore
defend and support the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine
using all tools at our disposal
we will focus on a strong and united
stance against russia
as well as the maximum possible
assistance to member states when
providing military support to ukraine
or when compensating for the
consequences of the migration wave
it is also very important to look in the
future
at the last european council we've
managed to approve the candidate status
for ukraine and moldova i'm very happy
that in this regard we had massive
support from the european parliament as
well i would like to use this
opportunity to thank you for that
but that must not be the end
another very important task of the czech
presidency will be preparing for a
post-war reconstruction of ukraine we
have to focus mainly on
reconstructing their infrastructure
providing basic services
their economic stability and recovery
that is where the eu must play a
fundamental role after all we discussed
this with madame fonda lyon
and we've demonstrated this on monday at
the conference
on the reconstruction of ukraine in
switzerland
the way of ukraine to the eu will still
be long
but together we need to strive that this
be a successful way that this make the
eu stronger
the second priority is energy security
the current crisis has fully shown us
how much the future of the eu is
existentially dependent
on others and how important it is to be
independent especially as far as
countries
which are threatening our safety are
concerned i'm talking about russian gas
oil and coal of course the way of the
czech presidency will be
the way of common european projects
which will rid us of our dependence on
russia
the czech presidency will focus
on issues of energy security
to make sure that we can implement
re-power eu as fast as possible and that
includes our energy resource
diversification we are ready to work on
coordinating gas storage facilities
before the winter we support
voluntary common acquisitions
according to the model that we've used
during the covet crisis
while doing all that we have to remember
that we may find ourselves in a
situation where more than ever it will
be necessary to show solidarity between
and among member states
we must not forget
building energy resilience of the eu for
the future through developing our energy
infrastructure at the same time we need
to support
all
eu
emission-free energy sources because
these play a very important role when
providing energy security in the eu as
well as in meeting our climate goals
the long-term goal of decarbonizing the
european economy
goes to a great extent hand-in-hand
with a short-term
goal to de-russify our energy supplies
and that's
that must be our viewpoint
in this regard to become energy
independent on russia we have to use all
options that are allowed by our
geographic situation given the size of
the eu and the number of member states
we may not apply a one-size-fits-all
approach every member state needs to
have the opportunity to choose such an
energy mix that is the most suitable for
their particular conditions and using
which they will be able to meet both the
climate climate targets as well as the
target of becoming independent on energy
supply from russia
if we indeed want to meet our climate
goals we have to be able to
finance them in the individual countries
i'm mentioning this because today ladies
and gentlemen you will be voting
on the objection against the so-called
taxonomy as introduced by the european
commission i would like to stress
that this is a very fragile proposal it
is a balanced proposal
a proposal that
makes it possible for a number of
countries to meet their commitments
stemming from our climate goals
only
thanks to criteria that were presented
in the proposal therefore i would like
to ask you
to
not reject this very fragile compromise
nuclear energy and gas as a temporary
energy source from safe countries
are the only tool that many countries
have at hand
in order
to
achieve our common climate goals in the
next years
the war in europe has shown how
important it is to boost european
defense capabilities as well as the
safety and security of european
cyberspace that's our third priority
given the current geopolitical situation
it is of key importance that we boost
european safety and security and defense
capabilities nato is in this matter and
natural partner to the eu and the
implementation of the key issues within
the strategic compass is the appropriate
framework we shall work on boosting
european cooperation in um boosting um
defense capabilities it is of urgent
importance to top up the military
warehouse provisions together with that
member states have provided to the
ukraine we also consider it of great
importance to
develop our defense industry and reduce
our dependence on
not
trustworthy countries in the long term
we shall work
on
facilitating joint purchasing of
military material
we are also facing new types of threats
that are being used by our enemies we
shall therefore focus on cyber threats
and making europe more resilient um
vis-a-vis outside threats such as fights
against disinformation the safety of the
cyberspace as well as key eu
infrastructure protection including
institutions
protection and that's what we have to do
together with our partners and allies
our fourth priority is strategic
resilience of european economy
it was the kovich pandemic that has
shown some weak points in european
economy one-sided dependency on some
countries
europe must
be
indus an industrial and technology
leader
for that it is important to have a
well-functioning
single market without unnecessary
obstacles only that will boost
our european companies
we therefore have to understand the
supply chains better
and make them as short as possible so
that the availability of strategic
resources and spare parts is always a
matter of certainty
what plays a key role here is boosting
free trade with other partners who share
our values the more free trade
agreements of quality we have the more
we can diversify
our contacts and supply chains what i
consider important is also the
digitization and automation in european
industry which also must lead in
innovation and new technologies as far
as strategic resilience of european
economies concerned
food security is of utmost importance
europe has become self-sufficient
in food however the war in the ukraine
also has its implications on food
security and the european union must
respond
we should not forget about the
importance of providing
food
in all parts of the world including the
most vulnerable ones not only because
destabilizing in the food area would
represent
a threat
to europe ronald reagan said that
freedom is never more than one
generation away from extinction
the same can be said about democracy
that is why
it is so important to have resilient
democratic institutions
and that is our fifth and last priority
long-term prosperity and stability of
europe
is based on functional democratic
mechanisms
our society is our
the targets of attacks
by those who have a problem with
democracy with human rights etc and we
must defend those values that is why we
shall always support
and boost
the freedoms fundamental human rights
civil society free media as well as
independent institutions
across europe
ladies and gentlemen there is no doubt
that
um we are facing a difficult time not
only due to the russian aggression in
the ukraine we are fighting increasing
inflation ever increasing energy prices
in some countries rising unemployment
in some countries we're facing the drop
in the gdp
we should not
therefore forget about those
citizens who are bearing the brunt of
this socially we must not
uh forget about those in need i can
reassure you
that
those are issues
that we shall focus on in a systematic
way
ladies and gentlemen
the six-month presidency is indeed a
short time
however i can assure you that the czech
presidency is ready to take its role
actively we are ready to focus
on an open dialogue to seek compromises
and functional solutions in cooperation
with other eu institutions
i believe that we will be able to
deliver our promises i hope that with
our help ukraine will soon be on the way
to full recovery i also hope that we
will be successful in the fight against
inflation
in ensuring energy security employment
and increasing the competitiveness of
our economies
i trust that we will be even stronger
than we are now
ladies and gentlemen i am convinced that
we can count
on
help on the help of the european
parliament which is a pillar of european
democracy
we highly value
democratic divides debates on this floor
and i'm looking for forward for
our debate thank you very much for your
attention
thank you so much
prime minister
for that comprehensive overview and
introduction i give the floor now to the
president of the european commission
ursula wonderland
viendank
thank you
president mrs matsuola dear roberta
prime minister dear peter
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
we
can all bring to mind the images of
russia's invasion of ukraine when it
started
ukrainian citizens where had no weapons
and they stood tall against the russian
soldiers spoke with the soldiers shouted
at them
flagged quite frankly how absurd the war
was
those images
remind us
of a different invasion and another
example of resistance against oppression
in prague in 68
we saw unforgettable scenes of peaceful
demonstrators taking to the streets
of prague and standing firm against
soviet tanks
and so i cannot imagine
a better country one more suited to
taking over the rotating presidency of
the council in the european union no
better country than the czech republic
the czech people have suffered under
oppression and the people in the czech
republic
know all about resistance the power of
hope
and the joy that comes with free
democracy
now more than ever
we need to strive for freedom
self-determination in the european union
so my dear peter i look forward to the
czech presidency of the european union
over the next six months
are enormous
you better have sum them up with three
words
rethink re-power rebuild
and of course the word rebuild calls to
mind first and foremost the
reconstruction of ukraine
i've just returned where i met you also
peter from the lugano reconstruction
conference
and i think we witnessed a very
impressive presentation
of ukraine's reconstruction plan
representatives from
more than over 40 countries and
organizations agreed on the lugano
principles
ukraine owned
reform focused
transparency
accountability and rule of law
democratic participation
gender equality and inclusion
and sustainability and i think these are
good principles now we have to fill them
with life
and for doing that we need the best and
the brightest on reconstruction
and this is why together with the german
g7 presidency
we will convene such a high level
conference after summer because we all
know never ever before have we mastered
such a colossal reconstruction challenge
so we need all hands on deck
and while we work in these days to help
ukraine win this war
we must also make sure that ukraine wins
the peace that will for sure come
you honorable members
were the first to call for the european
perspective for ukraine
and this led to the historic decision to
grant ukraine candidate status
i think we can all take pride in this
because our union lived up to the moment
we did exactly what vaclav havel
reminded us of
in his speech which also provides the
motto for your presidency
he has said
it is not
that the united part of europe would
come to harm if it expanded
just the opposite
in the long run
it would come to harm only
if it failed to expand
and i think in these days
that really sounds like a prophecy
now the second task you the czech
presidency identified is repower
the unity and the resolve we show
towards russia will also be key to
re-power europe
and this means primarily
to push forward the very ambitious
agenda of our european green deal
because climate change will not wait
till putin's war is over
and the unprecedented heat wave that
recently struck europe is just the
latest reminder of that
now i'm very glad that both parliament
and council
have taken their positions on fit for 55
so now it's up to the czech presidency
to bring forward the tri-logs
and i'm also very grateful for your
commitment dear peter to bring forward
the re-power eu package
with 3power eu we are mobilizing
substantial substantive new resources
for renewable energy
it is a 300 billion euro plan
to win independence from russian fossil
fuels actually from any fossil fuels
and to do so
we are first and foremost diversifying
our gas supplies away from russia
towards trustworthy reliable suppliers
and our efforts are already making a big
difference i have reported several times
here in the parliament about that so let
me update you about what the latest
efforts are
since march global lng exports
other than russia
to europe have risen by 75 percent
compared to 2021
and lng exports from the united states
to the european union have nearly
tripled
i think even more important is
that at the same time
the average monthly import of russian
pipeline gas to the european union
is now sharply declining by 33
compared to last year
last year june last this year june minus
33
so we are making progress and that's
exactly what we wanted to have
but we know that all of this will only
work the diversifying away from russia
and having energy security of supply if
we speed up the transition to renewable
energies this is the key remedy
now i observe that some say
in the new security environment after
russia's aggression
we have to slow down
the green transition
and this transition would come at the
cost of basic security they say
just the opposite is true
if we do all nothing but compete around
fossil fuels the limited fossil fuels
that are out there the prices will just
go through the roof and we will fill
putin's war chest and that's exactly
what we do not want to have
and therefore the best the cleanest and
safest way out of the dependency of
fossil fuels are renewables
so
the new security environment
is the best argument to speed up
deployment of renewables
with a home grown
they give us independent from russian
fossil fuels
they are more cost efficient
and they are cleaner than anything else
so let's take the opportunity and really
invest in the renewable energy
honorable members
but we also need to prepare now
for further disruption of gas supply and
even a complete cut up of of russian gas
supply
just to give you
a figure today
12 member states already directly
affected
by partial or total
cutoff of russian gas
so it is obvious
putin continues to use energy as a
weapon
and this is why
the commission is working on a european
emergency plan
we will present this plan and the
necessary instruments by mid-july
member states have their national
contingency plans that's good
but i think we need european cooperation
and we need common action as 27.
we need to make sure that in case of
full disruption
the gas flows towards where it's needed
most
we have to provide for european
solidarity
and we need to protect the single market
as well as industry supply chains
and here honorable members
we should never forget the bitter bitter
lesson that we learned at the beginning
of the pandemic you remember it very
well at the beginning we had egoism and
protectionism close borders export bans
you name it that led only to disunity
and fragmentation
but with european unity and coordination
we then after a while had the key
remedies to overcome this brutal
pandemic
so let's keep these principles in mind
as always let's hope for the best but
prepare for the worst i know this is
hard work ahead of us
but like in the last month unity will be
key to our success
madame
deputy
honorable members
you know
as well as i do
that in all member states
there are worrying economic trends the
covert crisis
has deepened debt levels and just when
economies were starting to rebound
russia began a ferocious attack against
ukraine this accelerated inflation in
all
sectors
the food sector the energy sector and
all in between
at the same time investment is key
to ensure a transition a green
digital resilient transition and that is
why we need to rethink
rethink my dear peter
is part of your motto and it is very
appropriate
we need to rethink the way
we drive growth
we have a very different political and
economic context we know the rules of
economic governance
we need
rules that recognize our need for
investment and the need for healthy
budgets
the budgetary
viability
and indeed growth go hand in hand
we will present the results of our
assessment of economic governance during
the czech presidency look at the single
market
you talked about this
you talked about our trade relationship
these are two major assets in tackling a
crisis the main drivers of growth
we need to rethink the way we can
strengthen those assets further we need
to look at new
free trade agreements one for example
signed last week with new zealand that
is a good case in point
the new agreement will help to bring
about a 30
increase in trade between the european
union and new zealand
for the first time
it enshrines unprecedented commitments
on social and climate issues
this shows
that when democracies are strong they
can deliver results in the interests of
their citizens in his
speech
vats love harvard spoke about
europe as a task
the task of europe today he said
is to rediscover its conscience and its
responsibility it's beautiful and of
course
and this is exactly what we will
continue to do with the support of our
czech friends
dear petter
i've seen it with my own eyes and heard
what you reported to me when i visited
czechia last week and thank you again
for this wonderful reception
the czech people opened their hearts and
their homes to refugees
they do miracles to thousands and
thousands of ukrainian refugees hosted
in the czech republic
and this is
in the harvard sense
europe with a conscience and taken its
responsibility
this is europe at its best long live
europe thank you
thank you very much
yeah
commission president uh before we go to
the round of political groups i have one
quick announcement uh in relation to the
decisions
by the imcon econ committees to enter
into inter-institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule 71 paragraph 1
announced at the opening of the session
on monday 4th i have received no request
for a vote in parliament by members or
political groups reaching at least the
medium threshold the committees made
therefore start the negotiations and now
on behalf of the epp group i invite the
group chairman for the weber to take
this line